In this lecture we're going to continue an
earlier discussion about image processing
and pick up on a couple of more advance techniques
that are interesting and useful. Image processing
is are really huge area.
There are some massive textbooks that cover
it in a lot of detail. Much more detail and
than I can hope to do here. But I want to
just introduce you to a couple of techniques
that I think really are useful.
The first thing we going to reveal is the
mathematical morphology. And where we left
it, we could use shape filters that could
detect squares or rectangles of different
sizes. Here we going to extend that and look
at how we can detect shapes that are perhaps
diagonal lines or circles.
The second technique we are going to visit
is what we call image warping. This is a fairly
general technique that allows us to change
the shape of an image and we are going to
look at some examples about how we can make
an image larger or smaller, about how we can
rotate an image or about how we can shift
an image.